a vita stories oggi trucchetti e case
pendenti primo gadget trucchetto si son
il secondo tecnico tempo è un ragazzo di
amare gesù pur iscritto a si trova la
faccia di magie strada c'è un piatto poi
sembrava insomma un caso la normale ci
sarà una scatola di arance di miniera
100 cv ahahah
allora per far contenere primo gadget lo
appoggiamo e poi devi donare al primo
gadget una moneta una moneta vediamo
allora va bene mi devi appoggiare qua
[Musica]
[Risate]
e per amore così spacco zampanò paese
povero gattino tra l'altro borse tipo
cosa dice
si no
[Musica]
ho frenato rispetto al gattino dammi io
rosati
io lo aspetto qui gli staccano zampanò
la base di un furbacchione questo gatto
prova a scuotere perché center si
determinerà un modo giusto
ci sono altre se lo prende lo stesso
colorino giugno andiamo se prende una
tetta finta di cereali un po grave
vediamo è rimasto un po perplesso detto
no l'ha buttata per terra come tutti i
caduti perde un po di close1 scrissi a
forma di zampa arrivato non devo venire
avuto da prende sta pensando a votare
sicuramente ci odia operano aggiornato
fini vediamo se prendevi elastico gatto
si fa pensando magnano a buttarlo giù no
io li sordi simone gatto che volete
vediamo un po dalla vetta per unghie le
unghie ora ci stiamo le vicende
rappezzato stanotte vi ruberà tutti i
soldi mentre dormite così bollate
prendermi allora che ne pensi di questo
caso il trucchetto per i soldi e questo
gatto fur disse pronto tutti i soldi e
lascia tutto il resto non è che abbiamo
qui lo lascia
secondo me utilissimo tipo se fate una
festa al caso se arrivano ospiti a casa
di te beh c'è una monetina per vedere il
gatto è la prima peter vostro salva
dalla benissimo
ottimo grazie a casa un punto
interrogativo ma chi è detto molto
misterioso
[Musica]
apriamo un po questa scatolina
misteriose come questo faccia dentro c'è
scritto giochiamo a un micio tanta tanta
classe disegnato un labirinto c'è un
simbolo del dollaro
[Musica]
c'è scritto se vuoi ricevere il tool
regalo devi risolvere il labirinto di un
po
[Musica]
piero dei diritti è un sacramento io
dovrei dire labirinto pubblico per
mettere i soldi le classiche o per
ricevere inoltro premio e far aprire la
cassaforte il gioco dobbiamo fare
arrivare la pallina tua prima radicale
[Musica]
giudaica per l'ingegnere certo media non
è certo che non ci resta allora vediamo
se rispetto per chi tale rese al ritorno
sto dicendo vorrei tale vediamo un po
come messalina sono quasi addirittura se
l'è già fatta ma perché io sono un genio
del loro di solo il castrato doveste
[Musica]
quando l'ultimo regalo centro invece di
regalare soldi regali questo così la
persona si deve guadagnare forza ho
capito ho capito
piano piano ma qui tra queste pagamento
perché poi gira dal porto incastrato di
nuovo allarme 6 dall'altra eccoti forse
qui
e ora di fare non capisco forse devo
andare di qua o nell'altro entrata ma
tutti rotti per i sei parà le piazze
alle 20 in mente che finita la pallina è
rimasta castrata file per chiedervi di
chiuderla con questo e poi puoi
riattivare il gioco i soldi vanno aveva
dentro non riesco
ma se bisogna prima di attivarlo e poi
dopo si richiuda 2 marino in questo
molto grazie io provo a dare al piatto
vediamo come reati sia di 20 euro
[Musica]
ritirati voglio vedere se funziona si
riprende com mar
[Musica]
non c'è riuscito bene se vi sta
arrivando infine
ora vediamo l'ultimo grazie tutto
trucchetto questo gelo far abitare un
trucchetto perché anche per quelli nota
dai vediamo allora questa è una
macchinetta segreta che con la sola
forza della magia riesce a trasformare
delle banconote duplice si creda o metti
5 a 1 the nascono 10 si crea dal segreto
no quindi un trucchetto di magia
giocatore maggiore tutto logico o meglio
ai trucchetti di qualsiasi manieri ti
stupirò ma su questo è l'unico
trucchetto di magia pericolosi perché
vorrei saperne anche altri ancora lunga
l'uomo pietro pediatre allora altro però
sono un brano umago riesco a fare
sparire il cibo guardare ad apparire
solo quello che dico m tipi le reti
video di euro quindi come funziona
aspetta fammi vedere per prima di
vedersi noto colpito dice cosa vogliono
e truffano accecarlo strade sono un
concetto di plastica non è che stampa
stampa stampa con l'inchiostro con
l'inchiostro sappa
io no si no quindi cosa devo fare la
devo mettere gli studi di 23 soldi ft10
eurobet ti faccio trasportare trasforma
mi raccomando non farmi gli sbagli
perché vi servono linguaggio a sparire
dipende quasi devo mettere in mezzo
aspetta a vedere bene i miei sud
vai vado proprio aggira guarda lì sta
appiattendo figlio che ora facendo
diventare l'eroe
no sybille e cosa no sono veri veramente
cosetto lo stampo oh mio dio capito 10
euro ne sono diventate 20 sono centro
famiglie adesso caso no non cadono tipi
di merci uomo e sullo scudo ed escono
tantissimi 20 euro di cui 120 euro ma li
puoi trasformare in qualsiasi cosa che è
vero e posso trasformare questi venti in
500 perché no agli moltiplica e basta
con 8 squadre a firehole e scopi niente
non ha ancora finito e se io metto
qualcosa che non sono soldi tipo per
collegata e io pensavo questo cartoncino
però forse la consulta portando il
contributo non veniva indagato a dei
soldi quelli del cartone è sì e non
funziona se metto un amuleto cosa
succede se volete sono troppo 8 no
future l'abbia tir e quindi non capisco
una specie di di stampino stampino magia
hai detto di una mozione
cercherò di non capire come funziona
questo coso e implica anni i soldi del
monopoli
ah sì vabbè ma di quelli non me ne
faccio niente col napoli qui diventano
ricchissimo ma non aveva tenuto bene ed
io me ne vado sono arrivato mano vado
non fa niente io infilerò qualcosa qua
dentro un figlio era un pò di banconote
poi me ne vado parto ai caraibi non lo
rimuova trovati rete magica non bastasse
così povera libera bieber fatti che poi
non mangi più e abbiamo quindi con un
pezzo di carta ma allora ok vado pure
non pezzo di carta poi dov'era in realtà
grande e piccolo medio deve starci qua
dentro
bene anche essere un pezzo di carta
bianco ok vado a prenderlo ok non dentro
un brutto pezzo di carta l'ho tagliato
bene che penso che ci sia ma andiamo
asperità aspetta vediamo se la
dimensione giusta
il motivo più rialzato la maggiorata
dimmi prima in casa non trasformi lo
trasformò in chat matelica voglio quello
kat line no voglio vivere così vado a
comprarmi il cibo va bene siamo compri
parma li trasforma in 50 euro complice
come io volevo comprare
un po di sushi vegetariano allora sì
bene allora aspetta tutto il web
questa volta voglio vedere bene bene mi
portate via servito di capire come
funziona vediamo allora io li metto
quali spetta oa giustozzi dimesso
io sono feriti ma chi mi chiede questo
modo possiamo andare a votare tutto
quello che vendeva mario che bello
credere se vi rimetto dentro o ti ho
paura però vive bene ci proviamo
proviamo posso provare io pensavo si
dice che funziona che se proprio io
noi proviamo allora quindi tu metti i
soldi
metti 50 che abbiamo trasformato prima
vado infatti la sto facendo qualcosa già
fatti noi le trasformati in 10 euro da
50 anni hai perso 40 euro con sei brava
non la magia dello stock a valenti di
qualcosa che dobbiamo dire la cedu che
non sai usare la magia e per 40 euro ma
ci sarà più niente d compreso le
patatine e piazzata a far ritornare
kimchi kabul a qualcosa di una nota
faccio che la mia mano magica è almeno
sordina io devo far tornare perché io
a tornare a molto visto che faccio non
sarà la magia sono io riesco allora tu
metti i soldi ma io provo a farlo
ritornare va bene vediamo io ti ho
avvisato dai dai che dobbiamo andare a
mangiare
devo girare questa notte facendo
malissimo foglietto bianco 50 lavoro
senza inchiostro che non sono beppe
rossi bano con la magia che lo stavano
tutta mangiarlo non ti preoccupare io ho
troppi dopo ha tante cosa mi dicono ti
dicono ci dicono chiama la polizia
come carne realtà sono i veri 50 euro
che sono state scoloriti da questa
macchinetta maleki casa pro nomine
tellina una macchietta magari mi
restituisce privè certo prof
vediamo ha cercato di prendersi questo è
il test finale se li gatto li prende
vuol dire che sono veri l'eurotower
giocattoli brad persino gli otto vacca
pieno
a fine diventano beni piaceva tanto per
davanti ero sotto modo diverso solo 40
euro adesso nei prossimi quattro anni
l'immagine che conviene ripararla questo
assassino per che però non fanno neanche
tu allora questi erano i soggetti e case
sui vissuti per oggi se questo video da
tutti e 10 mm se ne faremo un altro
episodio e cercherò anche di stancare
amici 50 euro
infatti nel nulla e ci sono più ma che
si sa bene quale grande tv bis si diceva
il piatto che come todi e la verità e
quindi riferito la macchina mangiasoldi
quale vaticana la stampante malefica
fateci sapere come e quando mi vesto di
che la resistenza del momento che io
faccio divertire di più senza figli ci
lasciamo cos'altro ben definiti gara per
vedere i nostri altri video cliccate su
quella che preferite